[Music]
laverne we have so much to talk about
first of all huge year the Emmy
nomination congratulations and cover of
Time magazine I have one of these but I
had it made at a mall you can hang it
you can put yourself in a cover of
anything I've done it you have really
helped give voice to the transgender
community how do you feel about that
well the trans communities had a voice
for a long time but now that voice is
being amplified more and I think it's
really about so many more of us coming
forward and saying this is who I am this
is my story and this is how it should be
told and you can't have a movement with
like one person so it's really about so
many amazing trans folks all over the
country who are letting their voices be
heard and saying this is who we are and
this is how we should be treated now I I
love I love the show and I was not aware
that your characters pre-transition is
played by your twin brother is that
right identical twin brother yeah
identical twin brother plays is this is
this correct he plays you in the pre
transition scenes that is correct and my
brother he's a musician whose name it's
a mallomar he's not an act he's not an
actor no he was on a funny he was on a
radio show and he was doing an interview
and he was telling and he was telling
story but he was on the subway once and
someone came up to him and said are you
Laverne costume or just new black and
you told the guy interviewing him that
that he and I was offended when he told
me the story that someone thought that I
was a man because my brother is clearly
a guy and he said that he was offended
that someone thought he was an actor
[Laughter]
you